what's your advice for other actors or
comics that car going up against the
same people I mean I know of a couple
people that have the same names on IMDB
and it's been competitive when they see
each other it's awkward it's it's
competitive because it's competitive if
you go into an audition thinking the
best person's gonna get the job and
that's never the case the best person is
never the one that gets the job it's all
about what do they need what type do
they need do they need someone that's
just tall does it have to look like the
kid they've already hired is this guy a
friend of the producers I mean there's
so many variables that is never a
meritocracy in auditions ever in my 25
years of doing it well there's a level
you need to be great to get up into that
to be picked from but there's no the
best and as long as you realize there is
no of the best then you can feel less
competitive with people that you see all
the time was that a earning experience
for you to come to peace with that
knowing that like yeah it's not a long
time it took a long time because you
know you're just like ah they were
better than me and they got the parts
like no no I mean they may have been
better than you but that's not why they
got the part there's so many reasons
that you will never know and no one
calls you and says hey that guy reminded
the producer of his best friend from
high school so they hired up I mean
there's no or someone you know there's
so many different variables it's
ridiculous so you just go in do your
best to bring what you bring to it
you're special take on it and then just
once you're done with that there's
nothing that's out of your control